un événement pour ouvrir ce journal est
un événement automobile l'événement on
peut le dire de l'année 80 la sortie
chez renault de la r9 cette nouvelle
petite berline sera situé dans la gamme
de la régie entre la r5 et la r18 je
propose de la découvrir tout de suite en
compagnie de jean-louis burgat 4 mètres
06 de long 18 cm de moins que la 305
peugeot la n 9 et la plus petite
européenne à trois volumes
c'est à dire avec un coffre arrière une
ligne très classique peut être trop mais
qui devrait bien vieillir pas de
révolution non plus à l'intérieur à une
exception près des sièges avant un
nouveau mode de fixation au centre du
siège laisse aux passagers arrière la
possibilité d'allonger complètement les
jambes et au système de bascule
permettent à l'avant de modifier en
permanence
l'assise du siège d'un confort rarement
égalée dans un petit modèle de ce type
une solution nouvelle aussi pour les
pare chocs avec trois zones différentes
à déformation progressive
le scl éléments déjà connus de la r9
c'est son moteur de au choix suivant les
versions 1 14 centimètres cubes sept
chevaux fiscaux et un onze centimètres
cubes cinq chevaux ce sont ceux qui
équipent les dix huit et cinq sur la r9
il est placé transversalement ce qui
permet un sérieux gain de place avec ses
deux motorisations et un équipement
pratiquement à la carte
renault présente 11 versions différentes
de la r9 en europe les consommations
quelles que soient les modèles s'étagent
entre 7 et 8 litre et demi au son au
niveau des qualités routières un grand
progrès la voiture se balance beaucoup
moins en virage jusqu'à présent le
défaut d'un certain nombre de renault
c'était une suspension trop souple à
cause de du confort demandé par les
ingénieurs de la régie mais sur l'a9 on
est arrivé à un compromis on concerne ce
confort et pourtant la voiture se
balance beaucoup moins en virage
beaucoup moins drôle y beaucoup moins de
tangage
regardez
enfin en ce qui concerne le freinage et
bien rien à dire de particulier il est
endurant et on freine correctement à
toutes les vitesses
oui
en même temps que les ingénieurs de la
régie tracé les plans de la r9 il
élaborait pour sa fabrication des
procédés nouveaux faisons appel à la
robotique celle usine de douai est un
programme de 2 milliards de francs
début novembre mille voitures sortiront
de ces chaînes par jour et fin 82 une
renault 9 américaine sortira de l'usiné
renault american motors de quesnoy dans
le wisconsin où la régie espère produire
800 voitures par jour
voilà il si vous voulez et mieux
connaître cette terre neuve vous pourrez
voir ce soir sur tf1
21h32 le magazine 7 sur 7 la conception
et l'élaboration complète de cette
voiture
ce n'est pas simplement un nouveau
modèle que présente aujourd'hui la régie
renault
c'est d'ailleurs pour cette raison que
nous avons choisi d'en faire le premier
sujet d'actualité de ce lundi
car l'automobile est un élément
essentiel de notre société
aujourd'hui en effet renault présente
donc l'espace un véhicule à mi chemin
entre la camionnette et la berline
traditionnelle une voiture salon une
voiture qui n'est pas simplement fait
pour aller d'un point à un autre
mais pour y vivre pendant le voyage
comme à l'intérieur d'un appartement
roulant jean-claude run and japonaise
non une renault espace conçu en
collaboration avec matra nivan ni
autobus ni berline classique c'est une
berline monocorps où tout est conçu pour
que les passagers puissent aménager
l'espace habitable à l'orgue
mais ne vous y trompez pas la renault
espace et rapide 175 kilomètres/heure
disponible en deux versions c'est une
neuf chevaux pour le fisc est une
cliente raisonnable pour le pompiste
le constructeur annonce qu'elle consomme
en moyenne 8 litres cette hausse en
l'espace donc une voiture ni trop haute
ahmed 66 ni trop longue 4 mai 25 en fait
un véhicule de loisirs ce n'est pas un
camping car mais on peut y habiter le
plancher plat autorise de nombreuses
combinaisons à partir de trois rangées
de sièges amovibles et modulable
inclinable pivotant équipés de tablettes
comme dans les avions
ils rendent au passage et leur liberté
mais me direz-vous pour quel prix
l'espace existe en deux versions 2000 gt
s 96 mille francs et 2000
tu es et ce sans 8500 francs celle ci
est une taie se met avec beaucoup
d'options de toit ouvrant peinture
métallisée deux sièges supplémentaires à
l'arrière qui sont en option et la radio
ce qui porte son prix à 123 1740 francs
l'espace sera disponible à partir du 15
juin
renault compte en produire dix mille ans
maintenant et lancera à partir d'octobre
deux versions turbo diesel
à l' usine renault dumont après la grève
qui a paralysé les ateliers hier leur
est effectivement la négociation une
rencontre entre la direction les
syndicats a commencé ce matin hors de
lusine dans un hôtel apparemment la
direction aurait accepté de discuter de
l'étalement des congés et notamment de
la cinquième semaine mais pas de la
réduction de la prime de fin d'année
ces négociations qui se poursuivent ouf
bien en tout cas que la régie entend ne
pas compromettre le lancement de la
nouvelle renault 5 qu'elle vient de
présenter
lusine dumont fabrique certaines pièces
pour la super 5 et la grève pourrait
allonger les délais de livraison du
nouveau modèle un nouveau modèle sur
lequel renault compte beaucoup pour
effectuer son redressement
la nouvelle ère 5 qui sera la seule
véritable nouveauté française du salon
de l'auto ressemble beaucoup à
l'ancienne vu de l'extérieur mais dès
qu'on prend le volant on mesure les
améliorations le moteur transversal
désormais c'est le bon sens de la r9 ou
le 14 cents de la ronde
le diesel comme la boîte automatique
viendront plus tard
l'aérodynamisme a fait des progrès meyer
cx 0,35 et plus de surfaces vitrées
à l'intérieur l'espace est plus généreux
notamment pour les coudes mais surtout
l'équipement général et particulièrement
soignée même si aucune des diversions r5
n'aura droit l'électronique des modèles
plus élevé dans la gamme
la planche de bord plus moderne a repris
la visière de la r25 on aime ou on
n'aime pas côté comportement routier
renault a fait de sérieux efforts
meilleur suspension 4 roues
indépendantes et barres anti dévers cinq
versions de la nouvelle ère 5 serait
seront commercialisés après le salon
tout en 3 portes
les cinq portes viendront dans un an de
4 à 7 chevaux fiscaux
ces modèles coûteront entre 40 de 1800
francs et 61 1900 francs
voici donc la sève
qui va combler dans la gamme mono un
vide important celui des voitures
moyennes entre la r11 et la r25 là où se
situe le quart du marché
il n'y avait plus rien depuis la
disparition progressive de la r18 la r21
c'est d'abord une ligne plongeante à
l'avant à l'arrière un coffre surélevée
et de plus grande capacité
c'est également 11 versions différentes
issues de cinq motorisations 2700
centimètres cubes à 2 litres une vitesse
de pointe allant de 176 à 200
kilomètres/heure selon le modèle de
boîte de vitesses quatre ou cinq
rapports et quatre niveaux d'équipement
autant d'éléments qui classe la r21 dans
la catégorie des voitures moyennes
supérieures c'est à dire en concurrence
directe avec la peugeot 305 la citroën
bx avec étrangères également aux 10 90
fiat croma fente sierra et puis opel
ascona ou volkswagen passat
pour les responsables de la régie la r21
représente un enjeu énorme 1 milliard
400 millions de francs ont été investis
pour adapter agrandir l'usiné de
sandouville la cadence moyenne de
production devrait être supérieur à 1000
voitures jour l'état majeur de la régie
renault est confiant et pense que les
vendeurs r21 vont favoriser le
redressement mis en oeuvre depuis un an
c'est une voiture qui regroupe toute la
qualité technique de renou et c'est bien
normal puisque nous y avons mis dedans
tout notre métier et toute notre
expérience
de surcroît c'est une voiture avec
laquelle nous gagnerons de l'argent
je trouve ça tout à fait normal depuis
hier l'offensive de la régie et complète
des pages entières publiés dans la
presse nous présente renault déterminer
depuis ce matin que ce n'est pas une
coïncidence la r21 sort au grand jour
première livraison en mars prochain
e